tonight
towing the slab into boogie down bronx
the one and only garrett cole and he's
been good this year
notice three walks against 50 strikeouts
it just jumps off the page at me amongst
all those other good numbers and the
scout report 30th and on base percentage
that one's popped up all four infielders
want it
and it's labour tour is the shortstop
who makes the play one down
the two one
hit shortly to first le mayhew will take
it himself two away
[Applause]
two two
swing and a miss running around on that
one
scuba making his sixth appearance
overall it's his first start
ground ball to short change up camden
rocks and deals
another hard-line drive that is into the
gap in right center field that goes to
the auxiliary scoreboard stanton's going
for two the throw from grossman nut in
time and stanton has an eight-game
hitting streak and a double big strike
zone though the 2-2
and that one is rifled to left harold
castro played it perfectly for round
number two
the o2
that one gets away from ramos
stanton
goes to third
the pitch
line to left field that's going to be a
base hit going to be an rbi
now stanton scores and the yankees lead
one nothing
[Applause]
the 3-1
deep fly ball center field and akeel
badou's got it just shy of the wall
2-2
swing and a miss
scope
down on strikes
all right let's just cut a little slider
off the dish
that works
you missed that by a foot
there's the one two
to willy castro
struck him out swinging high fastball
third strike out of the game for garrett
here's clint frazier he's nine for 60.
frazier rips one to left field that ball
is gone a bullet
into the seats in left field a solo home
run for frasier his second of the year
it's two nothing yanks the clint frazier
kind of eyeballing a lot of pitches not
really turning it loose boy all of a
sudden
the last couple of games yeah the swag
is back on ny
dot-com
pitch is cut out of this there's a
change
before he's throwing out the whole
repertoire
the o2
strike three badou down looking well
this is what you call getting worked
over
rookie hitter and one of the best
pitchers in the game
so
you can't do it if you can
it's true
the one two
struck him out swinging
that's a breaking ball
he has struck out six he just struck out
the side
one-on-one judge
driven deep to center field
there it goes
see ya
against the batter's eye
what a shot for judge it is
three-nothing yankees
middle middle at the belt
he destroyed this baseball so here's
aaron hicks he's in an over 18 slide
high fly ball deep left going back
castro track wall see ya
there it is breaking an over 18 slide
hicks goes yard it's four nothing yanks
it's like chicken soup for the soul for
yankees universe
bronx bombers are back
and the 2-2 pitch swinging and a miss
how about five strikeouts in a row
99 miles an hour
on the black
six in a row right now as cabrera down
on strikes
runners will go
three two two outs
[Applause]
strike three ramos down looking that is
the ninth strikeout for cole
is the second straight inning is struck
out the side but here is a chance for
the yankees frankly to blow the game
wide open they leap four nothing
they got the bases loaded one out and
aaron judged the hitter
high fly ball right field grossman back
track wall see ya into the second deck a
grand slam the other way for aaron judge
and the yankees are pouring it on they
lead eight nothing five rbis on the
night two home runs
and the pitch
sky down the left field line castro on
the run and he can't make the play and
it gets by him
torres will score
hicks will pick up an rbi double it's
nine
nothing yanks
2-2 cut out and missed
and i think that was a change
he struck him out that is strikeout
number 10 for cole
1-2
swinging and a miss 11 strikeouts
in five innings for garrett cole who was
absolutely dealing
i want to drill deep to right field
there it goes
see ya
into the second deck another home run
for the yankees oh door goes yard and
the yankees lead this one
by a score of 10 nothing
02 change cutout i missed strikeout
number 12 for cole
swing and a miss
swing and a miss
14 strikeouts of the tigers
two by sesa
reliable reliever able to throw strikes
more he's got dominating stuff and they
turned a guy that they picked up out of
nowhere into mike talkman a guy that
they really like as well
and goodrich strikes out
so that is now 15 strikeouts of tiger
battles
three and two on castro
litki deals
swing and a miss
2-2
swing and a miss
the 18th strikeout
did he go
yes he did 18 strikeouts by yankee
pitchers lickey
strikes out the side in the ninth inning
and then a friday night the yankees can
smile about five home runs 18 strikeouts
and they get the first win of this nine
game home stand david that's exactly
what they needed